das haben sie gut gemacht prima für Sie zu Hause
wir haben das zehn Minuten lang geprobt und es
funktioniert wie eine Eins wirklich sehr sehr
sehr sehr sehr gut gemacht ganz kurze frage ich
also normalerweise erzähle ich hier immer Witze
aber jetzt möchte ich einfach nur eine Geschichte
erzählen eine Frage wer von ihnen war in letzter
Zeit beim Arzt mach Handtuch weil das war was
schlimmes sollen wir darüber reden oder lieber
nicht also dann ist so nein weil beim Arzt also
ich muss es erzählen also ich habe einen Freund
das ist ja Nicki hallo Nicki und wir versuchen uns
gegenseitig immer so ein bisschen herauszufordern
ja also wir machen dann irgendwelche Sachen das
ist dann immer so ein Wettkampf ja also wir gehen
dann gerne mal so eine Wasserski station was sie
mit Kabeln also ohne Boote oder gehen in so einem
Klettergarten oder sonst was ziel ist es immer den
anderen so herauszufordern dass man auf jeden
Fall abkackt ja dann hat Nicki angerufen und
gesagt ich habe was dann dachte ich schon Mist er
hatte was und er meinte dann wir gehen erhoffen
genau mein Gesicht war ähnlich wie ihr es
ich dachte was mache ich erhoben und er Hop
ist folgendermaßen eine neue Trendsportart die
kommt hier auch noch nach Berlin es gibt hier
noch nicht aber es ist Wahnsinn und zwar wir
sind losgefahren wir kamen an einer Halle an
die Halle so groß wie ein Fußballfeld und dann
war die voller Trampoline alles Trampolin also
wenn ich jetzt sage die war voll die war also
es war alles ein Trampolin neben dem anderen
und dann kannst du da rumhütten und die anderen
so verschiedene Sportarten du kannst danach z.B
Volleyball spielen auf dem Trampolin Basketball
auf dem Trampolin schweren Kopf gestoßen am Ring
aber macht erstmal Spaß Völkerball an einem
Trampolin alles unter die haben auch so ein
großes Becken wo so Schaumstoff Quader drin sind
dann kannst du da so rein hüpfen für die Leute
die Parcours lernen wollen oder sowas immer an
den Salto fallen dann da rein was einem nicht
erzählt wird das Becken ist zwei Meter tief
ist dauert so lange bis er da wieder rauskommt
wie also dann dahin waren vorne an der Kasse
und fragten den Mann dann ja dann nehmen wir
jetzt jemand ein Tag und er meinte nee wir
verkaufen nur 15 Minuten 30 Minuten und 45
Minuten wie dann gesagt gut dann hätten wir gern
zwei Tagesdaten bei der nee noch mal aber egal
komm jung hier 55 Minuten wir also die 45 Minuten
gekauft da rein und losgeht nach fünf Minuten
habe ich meine Lunge ausgekotzt mir war nicht
bewusst Trampolinspringen ist mit Abstand das
wirklich selbst mein Schweiß schwitzte ich hatte
ich es ging nichts mehr also nach fünf Minuten
und ich wollte mir natürlich nicht die Blöße geben
weil er stand immer noch so neben mir gut er ist
auch sehr dick also durch das Gewicht aber egal
so dann sind wir also weiter nach ungefähr 10
Minuten war ich etwas bleich und nach dann 15
Minuten passiert eigentlich nur noch folgendes
und ich lag dann da
mein Körper hat einfach zugemacht das war aber
nicht das Schlimme weil ich war gerade in dem
Moment in einem kleinen Quadranten wo noch
25-Jährige mit mir Hüften und ich lag dann
da und dann Fingern neben mir immer zurück und
immer so hüpfen lassen das war sehr sehr lustig
irgendwann ist dann auch mein Kumpel nicht
aufgefallen du siehst nicht gut aus dann
meine ich ja das spüre ich auch ähm ich glaube
wir müssen zum Arzt also hat er mich eingepackt
also er hat ein Kombi mich hinten so in dieser
dann da rein geschoben und wir sind zum Arzt
und Ärzte da ist ja die Hierarchie wirklich noch
in Ordnung also erstmal sind auf dem Parkplatz
gefahren der hat ungefähr 20 Parkplätze also war
sein eigener Parkplatz war nur seine Praxis und an
jedem Parkplatz hin dieses Bild nur für Patienten
von Dr dr med genau so darf ich auch jetzt auch
ein Schild vornehmen machen können nee jeder
Produkt ist egal hatte schon leicht den Koffer auf
also wir dann da rein und dann diese Arztpraxis
also wirklich also wir machen die Tür auf ich
dachte ich stehe MoMA der da so ähm der erste der
mir da wirklich mal fröhlich der mich begrüßt hat
war so ein Chagall ja und äh der guckte dann da es
war so als wandvorhang kommt man die so zur Seite
machen und den Rest der Praxis wirklich Chrome
Tropenholz bisschen Kinderarbeit ganz ganz toll
also ganz ganz geschmackvoll und normalerweise
gibt es dann ja vorne so einen empfangstreet
das war kein Empfang ich hatte das Gefühl zwei
Frauen schwebten im Raum einfach so auf irgendein
glaskubistischen ich habe es nicht verstanden
und das ist eigentlich sind Ärzte nicht das
Schlimme schlimm sind diese Arzthelferinnen diese
schwarzen Löcher für Freundlichkeit und Sympathie
weißt du du kommst da rein guten Tag und
es ist weg es ist wirklich danke es ist
alles weg wirklich was die Menschheit seit 201
ist alles weg alles und ich stand dann da und
sagte halt guten Tag und es kam nichts zurück die
quatschten dann nur die ganze Zeit durch guten Tag
guten Tag guten Abend wird dann auch lauter
ja guten Tag und dann dachte ich okay du
musst irgendwie Aufmerksamkeit erregen und mein
Körper war noch irgendwie da drin darf ich kommen
tust du so als würdest du ohnmächtig ich also
wieder das ist eigentlich wahnsinnig eigentlich
ist es eine gute Variante sau blöd es ist halt
wenn nach 5 Minuten immer noch keiner reagiert
und du stehst wieder auf weißt du und die guckt
dich nur an sehen sie war doch gar nichts ne
sau blöd
und dann kamen wir dann so ein bisschen
ins Gespräch was ist denn los wenn man
nicht ja ich habe Schmerzen ne meinte kommt
das vom hinfahren nein das war vorher schon
und wirklich wir haben nicht so richtig
aufeinander also gut das hört sich jetzt
auch komisch an aber das einzige wozu sich dann
wirklich herabließ war was sind sie denn wenn
man wie was bin ich also ich meine ich bin
jetzt also Sternzeichen damit nein was sind
sie jetzt also die Geschlechterfrage stellt
sich jetzt nicht auch unbedingt bei mir also
können wir etwas machen nein das entscheidet
immer noch mein Chef gut was soll ich denn
deine privat und das war krass weißt du sie
privat mit diesen Augen so zu weißt du privat
und mich nicht mehr angeguckt weißt du was
hast du sie hatten ja eigentlich ins Gesicht
gespuckt weil sie dachte so und dann merke ich
schon hier wird das ist eine Schlüsselstelle
und da habe ich ein bisschen versucht
Zeit zu gewinnen also da habe ich
auch gesagt ja also ist halt Notfall das
entscheidet immer noch mein Chef ja privat
meinte ich sagen so ich zahle auch
und es ging immer so weiter und dann habe ich
dann wirklich gesagt nein ich bin gesetzt ich
bin wieder rausgegangen ich habe mich
nicht getraut draußen lief aber gerade
der Hausmeister vorbei und der hat gesagt komm
ich Rente dich wieder ein ist gar kein Problem
unter dem gebe ich jetzt gehe ich immer zu
ihm und er ist sehr sehr gut wenn Sie eine
Adresse brauchen also ist ein Top Hausmeister
danke schön ZDF hat einen Namen Qualität nee
also ZDF heißt ZDF und da ist
Qualität und wenn sie ZDF oder
drei hat es auch also öffentlich rechtlich schlau
abonnieren